bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo l'épisode 6 de Loki
saison 2 est sorti et bon sang c'est
quoi ce final de fou furieux Marvel
s'est dépassé avec cette série et c'est
tellement le contenu dont nous avions
besoin la hype est clairement là
sincèrement je vous le dis on va en
parler longtemps de cet épisode tout
comme l'épisode 6 de la première saison
qui était un point central pour parler
de l'avenir celui de la saison 2 c'est
autant voir plus d'éléments qui vont
nous permettre de comprendre le futur on
va avoir de belles théories à faire mais
pour le moment parlons de ce qui nous a
été montré et analysons l'épisode final
est bourré de belle symbolique et
d'éléments qu'il faut souligner après
avoir conquis l'érance temporelle
assimilé des siècles de savoir
concernant la mécanique la physique ou
encore l'ingénierie Loki parvient
finalement à faire installer le
multiplicateur temporel permettant
d'élargir les anneaux sauf que bien
évidemment cela ne marche pas et enfin
ENF on nous soulligne les limites du
cœur temporel le multivers c'est quelque
chose d'infini il faut voir ça comme un
arbre et je ne vous dis pas ça par
hasard bien sûr il y a le Tron de base
une sorte de branche qui va donner
naissance à d'autres branches qui
elles-même donneront naissance à
d'autres branches et ainsi de suite
multivers RIM avec expansion la solution
n'est donc pas là et cela va résulter à
une scène plus qu'incroyable et que l'on
attendait tous une discussion avec celui
qui demeure sincèrement la scène est ouf
et actuellement je trouve que rien n'a
rendu le personnage de kangle conquérant
aussi flippant et au-delà des autres que
dans cet épisode final comme nous
l'avions dit un peu plus tôt nous ne
pouvons pas gérer le multivers et son
concept d'infinité par conséquent nous
faisons face à la révélation dont nous
avions besoin le cœur temporel protège
simplement le flux temporel sacré et
lorsque nous atteignons la surcharge à
cause des autres branches celui-ci
élague les branches superflues
permettant de conserver ce qu' a établi
celui qui demeure mais au prix du TVA
par conséquent c'est comme on l'avait
dit dans les précédentes vidéos soit on
conserve ce qui est établi on protège le
flux temporel sacré on interfère dans
l'histoire on élague les branches et par
conséquent on reste sécurisé dans cette
prison créé par celui qui demeure ou
bien tout est anilé à cause de ces
variants à cause des incursions sans fin
qui engendrera la fin de tout ce qui
existe et c'est bien ça le problème soit
c'est la prison soit c'est la mort mais
il y a moyen de sortir de tout ça la
série Loki et sa saison 2 bien qu'il
nous permette d'établir une histoire
autour du TVA du multivers intégré Kang
et cetera le but premier est quand même
de permettre à Loki d'évoluer et
d'atteindre enfin son gloriious purpose
son destin glorieux et c'est à ce moment
que les choses peuvent changer Loki a
finalement compris que son glorieux
destin était orienté vers les autres il
veut sauver ses amis il veut que ces
derniers puissent vivre et c'est là la
grande différence avec celui qui demeure
il y a une énorme vibe Secret Wars des
comics dans la série loky c'est ultra
passionnant et on va en parler dans la
vidéo vous allez comprendre en réalité
celui qui demeure
profite de la guerre multiverselle Kang
le Conquérant est un personnage
solitaire un but lui-même et colérique
avec ses voyages dans le temps il se
sent comme un élu une sorte de Dieu et
bien évidemment face à ses autre
lui-même qui eux aussi voyagent dans le
temps bah il souhaite les aniler appuyer
son unicité et devenir supérieur celui
qui demeure n'échappe pas à la règle
cette énumération que je viens de vous
faire concernant l'essence du personnage
de kangle conquérant c'est pour vous
dire que ce dernier est centré sur
lui-même et Loki l'était aussi au départ
jusqu'aux événements du TVA Loki était
orienté sur lui-même sur son glorieux
destin sur le trône qu'il mérite d'avoir
et c'est là la particularité dont nous
faisons face concernant celui qui
demeure il profite de sa victoire dans
la guerre multiverselle pour être le
seul et l'unique il a établi son petit
royaume comme le dit Loki où il est sur
le trône qu'il a mérité grâce à ses
choix tout a été designé pour que he who
remains soit l'être contrôlant le temps
à la fin il n'est pas du tout en train
de se sacrifier comme Loki pour
permettre au multivers d'exister et
laisser les gens mener la vie qu'ils
souhaite ainsi que les protéger de ces
variants pas vraiment il essaie de nous
faire croire qu'il protège en en
empêchant la naissance d'autres branches
mais en réalité comme le dit
Loki et tout ça là c'est complètement
Secret Wars dans ce final il y a un
énorme parallèle entre la dynamique
celui qui demeure loky et rid Richards
docteur Doom nous protégerons ce que
nous pourrons il n'y a pas plus Secret
Wars je trouve comme phrase c'est
typique l'idée d'un battle World qui est
en gros une réalité et donc une planète
composée des débris des restes du
multivers qui vient de s'effondrer en
totalité à cause des incursions et qui a
créé battle World docteur Doom qui a
réussi à sauver des millions de
personnes grâce à son action sauf que
tout comme celui qui demeure il est
accroché à son titre d'empereur Dieu
battle World est un monde à son image un
monde tourné autour de lui-même c'est
son royaume il n'a laissé le choix à
personne et chacun doit lui obéir et
suivre un rôle imposé par ce dernier
même si voilà l'initiative à la base fut
quand même de sauver le multiver de
l'autre côté nous avons un Loki qui
vient d'atteindre son pic de
développement nous proposant l'une des
scènes les plus phénoménales de tout le
MCU Loki est bien loin de ce qu'il était
à ses premières apparitions dans le MCU
suite à ses Aventur dans le TVA et la
découverte d'éléments qui le dépassent
complètement il a appris et s'est rendu
compte qu'il ne voulait pas être seul et
plus que ça encore il souhaite sauver
ses amis qui sont prisonniers du destin
funeste imposé par les travaux de celui
qui demeur après une magnifique scène où
Loki s'entretient avec Mobius une scène
très intelligente car elle est issue de
l'épisode 1 saison 1 et vient répondre à
l'épisode 6 saison 2 soit en gros bah le
début et la fin de la série toujours ce
concept de boucle et quand on comprend
implicitement que cette scène permett à
Loki de dire au revoir à Mobius qui
était son partenaire alors que c'est en
soit leur première rencontre bref je me
répète hein mais la série est juste
incroyable loky comprend que glorieux
destin rime plutôt avec fardeau surtout
quand on est lié désormais à des
concepts qui dépassent l'entendement au
passage cette scène nous permet de
comprendre pourquoi Mobius n'est
finalement qu'un simple analyste à
l'humeur grisonnante puisque'à cause de
sa peur et de son inaction face au choix
douloureux le TVA a subi de grandes
pertes et au final l'élagage a été
encore plus traumatisant contrairement à
rensleyer qui elle n'a pas hésité ce qui
lui a permis par le biais de ce choix
difficile d'escalader les échelons du
TVA et devenir juge et par la suite
après une autre scène où lokis
s'entretient avec Sylvie nous
réaffirmant l'idée que celui qui demeure
nous impose soit la prison soit la mort
notre désormais héros va prendre les
chos en main pour tenter de changer le
MCU à tout jamais et d'ailleurs encore
une fois les détails et la construction
de la série sont au poil au moment où
loky time sleep et atterri lors des
événements de l'épisode 4 une ultime
fois le timing fait que nous entendons
un welcome he who remains avec un plan
centré sur Loki un détail qui a annonce
clairement la couleur puisque celui qui
demeure a tout conçu et tout orienté la
destruction du cœur temporel signifie la
fin de tout par conséquent Loki
désormais à l'opposé de celui qui
demeure fait le choix de ce sacrifieré
comme le dit Sylvie il nous offre une
chance Loki par le biais de ses pouvoirs
et de sa magie détruit le cœur temporel
part à la fin des temps et permet au
multivers d'exister il est parti
s'isoler avec les branches du multiver
pour les maintenir en vie Loki sacrifie
sa propre existence pour permettre aux
autres de vivre Loki sacrifie son libre
arbitre en maintenant le multiver en vie
pour que les autres puissent être libre
la formation du multivers désormais
remodelé Loki en son centre symbolise le
Tron celui sur qui le multivers se
repose il n'y a pas plus grand glorieux
destin il est désormais le plus grand
gardien du multiver mais son fardeau est
à l'échelle de son titre le multiver
prend désormais la forme d'un arbre et
je pense que vous l'avez tous compris
très vite mais il s'agit d'une très très
belle référence à
higdraasil l'Arbre Monde issu de la
mythologie nordique la même mythologie
dont vient Loki évidemment hiigdraasil
que ce soit dans la mythologie ou dans
le MCU c'est la représentation cosmique
des neuf royaumes dont fait partie
Asgard ou encore Midgar soit la terre
l'ensemble de leur placement permett la
représentation d'un arbre et chaque
royaume prend place sur une branche ou
une racine bref du coup pour revenir
rapidement à la comparaison que je vous
ai fait tout à l'heure avec Secret Wars
et pour la clôturer Loki s'apparente bel
et bien ici à rid Richards qui fait le
choix du libre arbitre et de la vie
contrairement à docteur Doom monsieur
fantastique fait le choix de relancer le
multivers et par conséquent son
expansion et tout ça nous le retrouvons
dans le final où Loki préserve le
multiver en étant en son centre et les
branches vont pouvoir continuer de
grandir librement cependant bien
évidemment ce Paris ce choix c'est
l'annonce véritable de la guerre
multiverselle à venir et d'ailleurs je
le place comme ça mais puisque le
multivers s'apparente désormais
symboliquement à ligedasil et bien
est-ce que ce ne serait pas logique
d'affirmer que la guerre multiverselle à
venir serait une sorte de
Ragnarok surtout que voilà dans la
mythologie nordique celui qui cause le
Ragnarok et bah c'est Loki et
actuellement Loki a fait le choix qui va
aboutir sur l'anéantissement puisque la
guerre est à venir bref le TVA va
pouvoir changer et tout comme le
parallèle que je vous ai fait avec les
choix de rid Richards nous nous tournons
vers une dynamique de laissons le
multiversagir aidons-le plutôt à
prospérer à s'étendre et grandir la
nouvelle propagande du TVA est
complètement dans cette direction
néanmoins qui dit maintien du multiver
dit retour des kanges comme on le disait
et le TVA désormais protecteur du
multiver va devoir faire attention aux
variants de celui qui demeure par le
biais de la référence à htman
quantumania on se rend compte que le TVA
est déjà en track et sur la surveillance
de ces derniers on nous parle d'un
variant qui a fait du grabuge dans un
royaume adjacent à l'univers 616 il y a
ici un petit rappel concernant le champ
quantique qui est une dimension àollé à
notre réalité on avait expliqué le
fonctionnement des dimensions dans de
précédentes vidéos si cela vous
intéresse cependant élément très
intéressant qu'il faut souligner c'est
que Mobius parle simplement et son
dossier est d'ailleurs basé juste lui
aussi sur Kang le conquérant de
kantumania sauf que vous le savez ce
dernier est un exilé du Conseil secret
des Kang étant donné que le TVA
surveille le cours du temps il surveille
donc les variants de celui qui demeure
au sein des branches néanmoins celui qui
demeure nous a averti qu'il est déjà
trop tard et il nous a averti au moment
où le seuil est fraîchement franchi et
où les branches commencent à peine à se
ramifier ces variants sont déjà là et le
fait que Mobius et le TVA se soi
simplement concentrés sur Kang de
quantouania nous révèle qu'il ne semble
pas savoir pour le conseil crosstime de
Kang et c'est plutôt logique car en soit
il serait déjà intervenu face à une
telle menace ce rassemblement est hors
du temps hors des branches ils ne
peuvent pas être détecté par le TVA mais
de l'autre côté c'est pareil aussi pour
eux pour le Conseil des Kang ils ne
savent pas pour le TV
personne ne le sait et c'est là que la
véritable guerre va pouvoir commencer et
si la scène postgénérique de kantumania
faisait référence à la fin de Loki
saison 2 Loki a laissé celui qui demeure
mourir il a détruit le cœur temporel et
s'est isolé à la fin des temps en
remodelant la formation des branches du
multiver Immortus associé à ramatout et
ce qui semble être le Scarlet centurion
nous a dit il commence à tou toucher le
multiver et donc que c'est une menace
pour ce que les Kang ont bâti ils
convoquent donc l'entièreté de leur
variant pour commencer la guerre
imortus ne ferait-il pas référence ici
aux actions de Loki car par déduction
c'est la première fois que le multivers
est autant touché entre guillemets Loki
veut changer les choses et donner une
chance à ses amis de réussir il vient
donc de toucher au multivers pour cette
cause à partir de là du coup le TVA va
commencer à détecter quelque chose
d'anormal puisque tous les variants ont
été convoqués et ramenés par Immortus
ramatout et Scarlet centurion qui était
dans l'ombre depuis toujours et pour
aller rapidement plus loin est-ce qu'à
partir de ce moment où le TVA va être
témoin de l'ampleur de la menace est-ce
que ce ne serait pas du coup l'avènement
de Deadpool 3 avec à son terme la
formation pourquoi pas d'une team de
super-héros du multivers comme il avait
été fait mention dans quelques news nous
aurons clairement l'occasion d'en
reparler il y a à partir de maintenant
moyen de faire beaucoup de belles
théories mais pour le moment j'aimerais
conclure sur une petite précision et qui
est présente d'ailleurs dans l'oky
saison 2 j'aime beaucoup le respect
apporté au Lord Marvel en fait l'un des
principes fondamentaux concernant le
multivers c'est qu'il est naturel et
c'est pareil dans les comics on retrouve
complètement tout ça dans Secret Wars
notamment et la série qui met bien en
place tout ça l'existence l'univers le
temps la naissance d'autres branches
tout ça fait partie du tout c'est
quelque chose de normal c'est comme ça
que fonctionne le monde de Marvel en
revanche ce qui va dénaturer le multiver
ce sont les actions des êtres qui en
font partie et pour ça on ramène le
concept d'incursion les incursions c'est
une réaction naturelle du multivers à
force de l'expérimenter de jouer avec le
chambouler avec des voyages des
changements de réalité modifier le cours
de l'Histoire et cetera et j'aime je
dirais même j'adore que loky saison 2
établisse bien tout ça loky épouse
l'idée que le multivers puisse exister
s'étendre et être en expansion sans
s'arrêter Mobius et Sylvie à la fin nous
démontrent aussi d'ailleurs cette idée
ayant désormais leur propre libre
arbitre et d'ailleurs il n'y a pas plus
belle déclaration d'amour de la part de
Loki que de donner à Sylvie le libre
arbitre et de l'autre côté quelle
tragédie par contre concernant Mobius
car Loki était tout pour lui c'était ce
qui l'animait et c'était le cas dès la
première saison bref je pense que nous
arrivons à la fin de la vidéo alors je
suis désolé j'ai peut-être été un peu
fouilli pour le moment il y a tellement
de choses à dire concernant ce final
concernant l'oki je pourrais en parler
pendant des heures mais voilà je pense
que pour le moment c'est largement
suffisant on se réserve pour de
prochaines vidéos j'ai vraiment envie de
lire vos ressentis en commentaire
n'hésitez pas à nous partager vos avis
c'est clairement dans ces momentsl qu'il
faut le faire n'oubliez pas d'ailleurs
non plus le petit pouce bleu et surtout
bah n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la
chaîne évidemment on se retrouve très
prochainement que le lion heart soit
avec vous les amis merci à la série Loki
d'exister allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]